SCHEIFELE AGAINST
MASON MARCHMENT ON THE
LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH HIGH ICE.DE.
TIP IN FRONT.
YOU BET IT IS.BARKOV.
WRIST SHOT AND GLOVE SAVE BY
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK AS BARKOV
PICKED UP.
FIVE FEET BEHIND HIM.
NO LOOK BACKHAN
HELLEBUYCK WITH THE LEFT PAD!
GETS ENOUGH OF IT!
SAVE AND BIG ONE HERE AS THE
MOMENTUM IN THE HANDS OF THE
FLORIDA PANTHERS.
THAT MAY HAVE GONE OFF THE POST
BRENDAN DYLAN WILL PICK UP AN
ASSIST AND PAUL STASTNY WILL
ENDS UP BEHIND BOBROVSKY AND
AARON EKBLAD ON THE LOOSENSKI O
NET AS QUICKLY.
RIMMED PUCK AS HELLEBUYCK THEY
WELL.
IN NINE SECONDS SAWR
WAY OR YOU DON'T GET
>> Dennis: 10 POINTS THE LAST
NINE GAMES FOR KYLE CONNOR NOW.
AND JONATHAN HUBE HASH MARKS OR
YOU CONTINUE TO LET THAT HAPPEN.
THIS GETS CLEARED AND CLIMB THED
GOALS WHICH IS TIED FOR NUMBER
ONE IN THE NHL. THAT
COLE PERFETHE
INTERIM TAGND AGAIN JUST GOOD J
THE PUCK TO THE NET HERE.
IF YOU W
ALMOST INTERCEPTED.
LOOSE PUCK TO THE GOAL LINE! WA
CAPITALIZE ON IT THAT SECOND
CHANCE.
GETTING PUCKS TO THE NET.
LUNDELL NUMBER nnis: CARRIES IN
FLORIDA ZONE SHORTHANDED.
AFK DESPERATION R L
FROM SAMBERG TO GET IT OUT OF
TROUBLE.
>> Dennis: THAT'S HOW THEY
STSTT GOES
TOVEOUGH, ONE,  FIVE-ON-FOUR.
>> Dennis: LAST SIX GAMES